so I need to use a lot of discipline so
I know I'm not doing something different
okay I have to chase this thing's
somebody you have this locked back way
this this mean this is heel weighted
okay so if he lets go and I stand here
that meant I was bracing on him so you
push this hold this knee is bent how far
eita toes okay so he's pushing and we
can do that under test to get let go
what he wants as fast as he can and you
see I don't go flying forward so when
I'm here like this and he lets go as
fast as he can
only you're gonna you're gonna have that
okay so we can do that test and since
I'm not racing and I'm vectoring instead
I don't need my my feet you see so he's
pushing bar he's pushing bar and you can
be as tall as you want I'm just still
vectoring down there right you can be
square doesn't matter anything to this
thing again you see you can be mobile
and still able to do okay so I want you
to play with those two tests and then
see who where was I if you find that
you're bracing still then it's you're
getting triggered don't want you to
understand it as innocent as just I
chose option B no he's triggering you
and you're trying to fight him
okay just stick to the form so if I feel
like I'm doing that a good new kid would
loosen up on you and go we're gonna
start again okay
or I feel like I'm doing this going to
go a little slower this woo oh you got
me okay and then I'm gonna try to do the
same thing again okay all right let's
try so I am taking this energy letting
it go through me and veteran into the
back foot but I don't want you to start
working with the dichotomy of stability
and then that's how are you doing so
that that's why I was showing you that
you can you can move and still you can't
do it because each foot is grounded okay
so in truth I'm going to show you the
beginner drill but you have to
understand it not solely from the
beginner perspective so the beginner
drill looks like it's about stability
but stability of the cost mobility is
marshal detriment so that cannot be it
okay the principal I gave you is
vectoring vectoring does not require a
static kind of static posturing it does
not that's why I can move with it okay
all right the next line the drill that
we're going to do now is to address the
corners of my body so we're going to pay
attention to my shoulders and my hips
okay don't do this as we did put them
where they go so imagine that you have a
beam across your back a beam across your
hips and then an i-beam connecting them
so that they move together they don't do
this okay alright so his drill is drill
one I'm doing drill one but I'm going to
now stress
this corner what some of you were saying
that was already happening
okay so I'm here like this and then I'm
gonna fold my arm and he's gonna go to
the elbow and because it was just energy
it doesn't matter I'm still vectoring
you see that and then I would have
released out and he's going to come to
the shoulder itself but it shouldn't
change anything should not change
anything and he can let go as fast as he
wants and you see it doesn't require me
to do that okay so again we're gonna
stress the corner here on I start to
take it away keeps the energy I start to
take it away and I miss ground being the
same vector okay and in the same way of
the last drill I do not need the i-beam
that has nothing to do with vectoring
okay so yeah okay you can have weird
things I'm still vectoring push you
could do weird it's still going down to
a greater mass than me do you see that
right at the beginning we're going to
use the four corner one two three and
then he's let's go okay so
his Energy's coming in or just vectoring
it to the back foot so that same thing
he's constant so it doesn't change okay
and it doesn't change it doesn't change
and therefore here you push other places
so if you push here and it's just going
to go down to the same back foot you can
take the other hand off you see and you
could let go and same exactly okay so
he's gonna go here and then I'm gonna
slowly take this middle one okay
go find it there you go
okay got it okay all right next my
pretty girl so we're gonna try to do two
things I would reach out to him and I
take him onto that back foot shot him on
the front foot and then I reached out
and I hit the ground cloud dang front
foot wait only and now I'm usually front
foot wait absorb boom onto the liquid
vector of the back foot let's do this
date this would be drills front foot
reach out let's go okay let's try we're
not I'm on the front foot push the front
foot is that is the vectoring foot you
see it's not I'm not having a crazy name
the the front foot is doing the three
for the veteran you see that okay so he
can push he's just rounding the front
foot so it's from a ground back green on
the front foot that I am released and
changed to the new ground you see that
so it's if I don't do that when I go
like that that momentum begin to God
okay so I reach out fold mean it's the
front foot and we're just hanging out
here until I decide I don't know you say
you can push it really hard and we can
move pushing your Mars energy shifting
you see and they're not changing the
ground vector do you see how I'm doing
that so I'm not here like this with no
nothing but a racing angle then I take
away the bracing angle okay if if I was
ground vectoring that's his energy
that's pinning me down so I read I am
letting his energy go to the greater
mass okay he should be doing the same
thing as again so he should be ground
vectoring dreaming okay maybe he
shouldn't have a weird corners right
you doesn't want to be up on his
shoulders see you kids doing the same
thing walking and should be able to move
okay if my three kids doing that he's
gonna help me learn what I just did he's
going to help me learn that from an
August point of view because he's
already structured for an a more
advanced skill is to do it when the guy
is not structured for okay so if you're
gonna come in as you kid you're gonna go
you're gonna go like this kind of stuff
energies going to travel outside of all
those things that might be true
letting energy travel outside when you
were knocking okay so don't waste 50% of
your training time his corners are
locked he's drawn vectoring the same
energy okay so here's the next row I
come in and come to the back and then
shift forward through okay now I'm gonna
do it again here front ground sweet
victory
background foot victory and then take it
back to the Frog without losing my
corner boom and it will project to my
hand because either you can fight the
mouse right
[Music]
good slow get all glazed the dish if you
can make it very small
okay so again the drill front vectoring
Bock put that current push bak and hit
what he's pushing with let's it's a
ground foot vector it's a four corner
stabilization okay so don't start adding
torch in here you just destabilize the
corners and now you're going to do a hip
rotation you could tell I'm in the
middle you see I'm mid weighted which I
didn't come to the front okay so I'm on
the back and I just stay here and I go
to the front
why don't I just stay here and I go to
the front okay now what you're doing to
is you won't go all the way to the back
you stay here go to the buck and boom
over to the front this further back you
go the more you get to go forward it's
the mortgage in the lorry on the less
year the less end the less gone you see
your have to go full bone to get what
you want you want you want him to go fly
I'm just working on the technique so
even going slow long that's the
technique that's the technique just a
little percussive a little dynamic but I
am still training going here and switch
keep the four corners in order
one two so this is so slow all right
this is so slow that you don't realize
you're being triggered when it goes
faster you get triggered and so you end
up clashing oh my goodness watching you
class okay
so slow bah forward this is another of
fear cycle response I was asked to do
the same drill
so I'm grounding this foot and I'm
pushing you're turning on it don't turn
their corners drop it anchor your
shoulder blade and these first back to
the front foot I mean the back foot that
trigger you're not vectoring that you
see get this energy to go ahead back
foot don't come forward yet okay here mm
come on then he goes and I like do you
see what I did I let the energy out of
my arm so now I stopped my drilling in
the four corner organization okay
and so 50% of my drilling is not
happening so instead I'm doing the same
drill or Bock here he goes and you
should be able to move me because I'm
locked so to expedite your skill the one
you can be thrown far the earliest is
the one he's going to learn how to
project the earliest and the most
because they have the body organization
okay
then one here
who's here and see I stopped pushing on
it you see that then I'm not there I'm
not brown bearing at all on this
standard here so if you watch we're
gonna do it I'm gonna show you how in
ground victory you see if that was the
same skill that he was doing to me right
when I just here and I'm like here and I
left I stopped and just standing on the
ground now
okay or I go here and then I feel the
projection and I start to let it corner
out see that no hold it and he goes oh
the reason why I do these weird things
and I can't do it fast is because I'm in
that fear cycle is the threat is
threatening to me
I have self-attachment is jacking me up
I can't absorb and let that in I want to
keep it out and it's the same thing I'm
doing here it don't want to be moved
okay
stop letting the energy out let's go